in this street market in seoul these
spicy ramyan noodles pack a punch
a staple for south koreans they're now
winning over pallets around the world
since the pandemic demand for oodles of
these spicy noodles have soared
leading south korean manufacturer non
shim says the pandemic helped to
spearhead a k food wave in america
canada and europe and that expanded
noodle sales by 24 last year over 2019
[Music]
the noodles has become the latest trend
in a growing western appetite for all
things south korean
that's including k-pop k-drama and
k-movies
non-shim sales went up after the
oscar-winning film parasite presented a
made-up dish called japa guri using its
product
korean brand samyang ramen saw sales
reach new highs after it was used in the
popular netflix show squid game
and k-pop band bts pushed international
sales of mandu or dumplings by 19
after two members got into a fight over
the food the korean way hollywood played
a huge role in the popularity of korean
noodles
things like bts like the worldwide
sensation bts and
just seeing ramyan in korean dramas has
played a huge role
people see it and they see that it's not
just something that we eat out of
convenience or something that broke
college students eat they see that it's
something that people really enjoy
the humble instant noodle isn't new to
american society it's a mainstay in
prisons as much as it is on a student's
plate
but south korean foodies claim their
brands taste better
and say there's only one way to eat it
that brings out that spicy flavor
i think it goes with the satisfaction of
eating the noodles when you hear a good
slurpee
so as westerners gorge on korean food
and culture will they also take up this
experience widely shared on social media
so about manly al jazeera